when the Rings off and the hat's off and
the crucifix is off your neck that
you're like you're gonna die and I know
those are reminders
hang on to what they mean for you
as we go forward but as we go forward
quit worrying about so much about it
you again I was looking at the
proverbial dream the cloud so much that
I was tripping over myself to get there
and like clockwork Just Amazing Grace
boom as soon as it hit me and I was like
ah that's it
all I want is what I can see and all I
can see is in front of me
literally looking down at the ground
at What was a sea of ten thousand Wild
neon blue Amazonian butterflies on the
ground
as soon as they fluttered up my head
came up with them
took a few more steps
there's the Amazon that's what you came
over here for oh howdy those kind of
that that truth like that well the
Amazon is interesting too because it
really has no past or future losing the
moment because how fast it churns it
just eats up life it like if a thing
dies it just gets swallowed up
because uh maybe because of the humidity
because of all that because there's so
many living creatures that kind of eat
each other live on each other
so it really exists in the moment
and all this kind of diversity of Life
there it's such an interesting place
talk about food chain yeah you're just
part of it there yeah
we we humans somehow Escape that food
chain but we're still the roots are
still there
are we here I think we're a bit arrogant
to think we've escaped
you think I'm being romantic in that in
that in that notion well sometimes when
you're in a big city
when you're in Austin Texas and L.A you
can think like oh there's we're in a car
when the house we're safe but
yeah somehow somehow's nature is still a
part of us Our Roots are still part of
us
I think it is more than we realize more
than we give it credit for I actually
haven't I
believe that we
are
but it's a really arrogant notion to
think that
we are separate meaning you know people
talk about
pollution and on a larger scale the the
climate what have you
I think Earth's gonna be just fine yeah
we maybe not be here for it but
I think we have a bit of arrogance
sometime to think that we
can Trump Mother Nature I think we have
more more of the natural law in us
um
and I sure hope so if I'm wrong